die ukraine braucht es in erster linie
waffen werden wir von spenden reden ich
habe es natürlich nicht da aber ich kann
auf das spendenkonto der ukrainischen
streitkräfte aus dem hut zaubern
beziehungsweise aus dem handy und sie
brauchen natürlich mehr als die spenden
von mir der ukraine steht mit dem rücken
zur wand das erklärte kriegsziel
russland ist es die ukraine auszuwischen
das unabhängiger staat als eigenständige
nation was putin feministisch als
entnazifizierung beschreiben ist nichts
anderes als ein ausradieren der
politischen kulturellen der
journalistischen eliten der
intellektuell
der westen hat allen grund außer sogar
aus einfach aus planken eigeninteresse
die ukraine hier militärisch zu
unterstützen
denn wenn die ukraine fällt wenn dort
wie in der dnr und teilen eher ein
besatzungsregime dass sich dann mit
nordkorea darum buhlt den letzten platz
in der freedom house ranking zu erfüllen
wären sich dass die ukraine nicht
gefallen lassen sie werden widerstand
leisten das wird den partisanenkrieg
geben was bedeutet das wiederum russland
wird zehntausende
truppen der inneren sicherheit also
nationalgarde fsp entsenden um diesen
aufstand niederzuschlagen diese leute
kommen von rot nach russland zurück
behandeln die eigene position wie es in
der ukraine gelernt haben und ukraine
versteift und russland verstärkt sich
darauf wie das team gestern schon
angeklungen hat dass der westen an allem
schuld ist das im grunde dass nur ein
produkt das hier ist und dass man das
altbewährte mittel militärische kraft
militärische einschüchterung dazu
gebrauchen wird um uns abzuschrecken und
ich sage das unter anführungszeichen
sich in die um nicht wieder
anführungszeichen inneren
angelegenheiten russlands einzumischen
das wird der putin-sprecher sein wir
werden keinen ruhigen kalten krieg haben
wir werden einen heißen kalten krieg
haben einen der äußerst instabil ist und
in einem in der die eskalation im grunde
jeden tag an der wand geschrieben ist in
dem sinne ist es unser ganz eigenes
interesse jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass die
ukraine in diesem krieg zumindest
militärisch unentschieden aussteigt auf
jeden fall überlebt als ukraine als
souveräne ukraine
paul du hast es hoffentlich gehört ja
was gibt es darauf zu antworten wie
viele waffen braucht die ukraine
wie viele es schwer zu sagen aber
definitiv kann ich sagen vor der sendung
mit vitali klitschko gesprochen der
heute an verschiedenen stellungen
unterwegs war auch hier in kiew muss ich
das ja so vorstellen um sie herum wird
längst sehr heftig gekämpft insbesondere
den außenbezirken da sieht es so ein
bisschen aus wie in teilen syriens
bereits so sehr schießt russland dort
mit
raketensystemen reinöhl es geht vor
allem darum dass man diese raketen
abwehren kann das ist kompliziert
zumindest teilweise und dennoch gibt es
dafür möglichkeiten und da sagt die
ukraine brauchen wir dringend viel viel
mehr soweit es die ukraine nicht mangelt
und das hat putin überrascht ist die
moral der truppen die man dort auch
treffen kann die wirklich überall
unterwegs sind versuchen hier auch hier
wo ich bin diese stadt in irgendeiner
form sicher zu halten es ist trotzdem
wahnsinnig ein geister stimmung dort in
den straßen fährt eigentlich niemand
mehr es läuft auch niemand mehr so
wirklich über die straße aber was die
waffen angeht sagt man das geht zu
langsam die europäer brauchen zu lange
man orientiert sich momentan eigentlich
vor allem richtung usa und das ist finde
ich ein wenig traurig dass wir europäer
da im vergleich zu den usa
wieder bürokratischer langsamer und
nicht hands-on sind ich glaube wir
müssten alles alles alles tun um
wirklich hier europäisch zu liefern denn
ich erinnere mich wie 2014 dort von
vielen eu politikern europäischen
flaggen verteilt wurden am mal dann ich
sag das jetzt mal symbolisch sie standen
zumindest mit dabei und die ukraine die
jetzt die europäische die damals die
europäische flagge gehisst haben gewählt
haben auf dem majdan die stehen jetzt
auf dem schlachtfeld und ton von putin
getötet zu werden herr zehn jahren die
deutschen wirklich so viel mehr als die
amerikaner vor allem mit blick auf die
sanktionen muss ich sagen also amerika
zaudert gerade ja auch ein bisschen mit
blick auf den energiepreis auf ihren
wird es dort auch debattiert wie man das
mit den bürgern schafft sind wir gerade
so viel schlechter im handeln als
amerika
die amerikaner haben auch mit einigen
sachen länger gebraucht zum beispiel
auch mit der flugverbotszone aber es war
nicht dicht es ist richtig was sie sagen
wir haben gezittert wir haben gezögert
und als schon alle anderen gesagt haben
wir brauchen die aussetzung von swift
was deutschland die am ende noch die
einzigen waren vorher noch mit viktor
orban die einzigen die dagegen waren
sind super hat schneller entschieden als
wir und insofern ja wir haben nicht
schnell gehandelt bis letzte woche
sonntag als bundeskanzler scholz einer
regierungserklärung abgegeben hat waren
wir diejenigen die gebremst haben und
die nicht geholfen haben dann gab es die
wände und die war richtig und das hat
schon das würde ich auch als opposition
sagen das was sie angekündigt hat war
richtig ich habe als der vertreter der
neutralität noch eine frage wenn man den
gedanken näher tritt also waffen waffen
waffen das ist ein einfacher gedanke
insofern leicht verständlich was wäre
dann ihr szenario wie das weitergeht
glauben sie dass man in der jetzigen
situation die er schon weit
fortgeschritten ist
der armee putins noch wirklich
widerstand leisten kann so dass das
passiert achtung meine these ist immer
noch im raum dass putin so viel schaden
nimmt und so viel gegendruck spürt dass
man überhaupt am verhandlungstisch mit
das eigene mann kommen kann ja also ich
würde hier die parallelen zu 19 39
finnland ziehen stalin war ja auch jetzt
nicht zimperlich und war jetzt auch
nicht der beste menschenfreund und hat
sich auch nicht um die menschenrechte
geschert aber irgendwann war es einfach
für die sowjetunion damals zu
schwierig oder zu zum problematisch dass
man hier in finnland vorgeführt wird
finnland stand natürlich auch vor der
totalen erschöpfung finnland hat aber
auch zumindest von schweden zum teil von
frankreich und großbritannien waffen
bekommen
um sich zu verteidigen
und es hat dann nach 40 tagen wir sind
das am tag noch in der kriege finnland
hat nach 40 tagen einen
natürlich schlechten aber einen
souveränen frieden und einem bewaffneten
frieden erreicht und wir sind zurzeit
wenn man sich die letzten
verhandlungsrunden zwischen der ukraine
und russland anschaut leider noch weit
davon entfernt dass putin einem
souveränen und einem bewaffneten einen
wehrhaften frieden für die ukraine
zustimmt wie immer daran ausschaut
ukraine die ukraine hatten ein sehr
lebhaftes parlament das müsste allem
zustimmen was die lenski aushandelt das
vergessen hier bei uns auch die leute
der der ist nicht gut in der iss sein
wort ist nicht ein macht aber wenn er
einen kompromiss aus handelt dem denen
die rhader zustimmt dann dann gilt der
und was dann genau drin ist dem möchte
ich nicht vorgreifen
bis dahin kommt ist noch viel
militärische widerstand zu leisten und
wir haben natürlich die logistischen
probleme der russischen armee die combo
ist die die formel kolonnen das ging bei
uns alles durch die durch die medien
aber das gilt ja für die ukrainische
seite genauso die russischen panzer die
hier alle abgeschossen sind die haben
sich nicht hin selbst in flammen
aufgelöst die wurden abgeschossen und da
wurde munition verbraucht und der
munition verbrauch war enorm auch zur
raketenabwehr die die ukraine hat es
geschafft sogar russische ballistische
raketen abzuschießen mit alten
sowjetischen flugabwehrraketen aber auch
die werden knapp und
desto länger sie das kann desto länger
seine luftwaffe noch betreiben kann
desto länger sie den luftraum zumindest
temporär freihalten kann solange sie
noch drohnen operieren kann die gegen
diese konvois gehen die auch artillerie
in der tiefe angreifen solange sie noch
eine funktionierende panzer abwehr hat
die die verhindert dass die stadtzentren
möglich eingenommen wird so lange hat
die ukraine eine chance einen frieden
auszuhandeln ja kein friedhof frieden
ist und er nicht auf potenziell passiert